our friend Dana Perino was of course the
press secretary in the George W Bush
administration knew mrs. Bush very well
and joins us tonight by phone Dana thank
you very much for coming on well how
would you sum up the life of Barbara
Bush well it was one of great
consequence and she lived a long life
you know 92 years most of it in pretty
good health
she's loved by her family and by the
rest of the world really if you listen
to the Ambassador from the UK who was on
with Martha but the news broke that
Barbara Bush had passed he was beloved
around the world and as the bushes had
made quite a bark on history but Tucker
I wanted to share something I think that
you as a father might have even
recognized in her but if I could
reiterate it one of the things that she
and George HW Bush did in raising their
children is they were determined to make
sure that everyone knew that they were
loved unconditionally and George W Bush
as president I'm sorry after he left the
presidency and wrote his memoirs
decision points he really took a lot of
time in that book to explain how
important that was to his future because
you knew then that you could take risk
and you could try something new you
could follow your passions do whatever
you wanted to do because if it didn't
work out your family was going to be
there and I thought that was such an
interesting parenting lesson lesson for
me to understand and try to pass on
because if you look at what they were
able to do in raising this amazing
family that is dedicated to public
service and also has kept some humility
and humor about them I really do think
that her influence was what drove all of
that for them I believe it I remember
one of our son's told me that the
pivotal experience of her life and of
course it makes sense was losing her
daughter Robin at the age of three to
leukemia and that it was the one thing
that still made her cry when she thought
about it but other than that she had
this kind of remarkable self-control not
in a
in a bad way but as a kind of matter of
cultural course she felt it was her duty
to keep herself under control in public
I wonder if we'll ever see that again we
ever have another first lady like that
no I'm serious I mean that is it it was
a specific kind of American style and
now it's gone it's interesting yeah
there is a lot to be said about dignity
raised and again humility and a sense of
humor I remember when I spoke on behalf
of President Bush if I ever had
something snarky that I wanted to say
something really sarcastic that would
have been a great singer and a really
good line to quote but if I thought that
she might be watching
I would swallow my work because it
wasn't worth her not being proud of us
yeah and it was really special to know
her and you know she touched a lot of
lives so I'm not saying I'm an expect
more special than anyone else I'm not
but I'm she and I bonded over the fact
that she knew I was going to be loyal to
her son as the press secretary and she
was also here she was also a lot of fun
I do remember one time my husband and I
got to meet them in May and I'm sorry
was in Houston and we were talking about
the importance of thank-you notes also
sort of an old-fashioned thing but a
tradition that I think you know I'm sure
you do Tucker and do Peter came back and
you wrote a thank-you note well I have
been traveling and I got back and he
didn't have the address so it finally
got there but it was about two and a
half weeks after our first meeting we
saw her not long after that and the
first thing she said to Peter was well
that was the longest time I've ever had
to wait for a thank-you note and now she
said it with a twinkle in her eye things
that you just did not want to disappoint
oh I had that experience I was going to
public place with her once in a gym and
I ran into my own wife and kissed her a
little bit too enthusiastically and Bush
gave me this look like none of that in
public which
I sort of appreciated anyway did pretty
thank you very much
I'm you're so welcome thanks under for
all this coverage thank you